Cuando en el año 2014 el entonces presidente
de Estados Unidos Barack Obama anunció su
intención de alcanzar un acuerdo con el régimen
de los Ayatollas sobre el programa nuclear
iraní, las relaciones entre Riad y Washington
comenzaron a resquebrajarse.
La vieja alianza, la antigua sociedad, la
relación especial entre estos dos países
que comenzó allá por 1945 cuando el presidente
Estados Unidos Franklin Roosvelt se reunió
con el rey saudí en el canal de Suez, empezó
a venirse abajo.
Para Riad el pacto de Washington con Teherán
fue poco menos que una traición.
Y desde entonces, las cosas han ido de mal
en peor.
Ahora la invasión rusa de Ucrania y la negativa
sistemática de Riad de apoyar la posición
y las peticiones de Estados Unidos ha puesto
las cosas peor que nunca.
Pero, ahora bien, ¿Por qué demonios Arabia
Saudi sigue apoyando a Rusia, y lo hace incluso
aunque eso pueda poner en riesgo su especial
relación con Estados Unidos?
¿Por qué las relaciones entre Riad y Washington
se han deteriorado tanto?
¿Qué queda de la vieja amistad entre estos
dos países?
¿Podrá Joe Biden recompener la relación?
En este vídeo os respodemos a todas estas
preguntas, pero lo primero, lo primero de
todo es saber dónde comenzó esta relación
especial.
[Y antes de todo, un anuncio que puede interesaros.
Os hago una pregunta, ¿Habéis escuchado
hablar del Metaverso?
Sí, estoy convencido de que todos, absolutamente
todos habéis escuchado hablar de ello, pero,
¿sabes realmente en qué consiste y qué
implicaciones tiene?
¿Es puro humo o realmente estamos a las puertas
de una nueva revolución digital?
¿Por qué empresas de todo el mundo están
invirtiendo miles de millones en esta especie
de mundo virtual?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, si queréis
aclarar todas estas dudas no os perdais el
último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el
canal de información financiera de Mutuactivos
con el que participamos.
Un canal en el que también podréis encontrar
otros muchos vídeos, entre ellos uno que
se pregunta si el hidrógeno puede sustituir
las importaciones de gas ruso de la Unión
Europea.
Os dejamos toda la info en la descripción]
Dicho esto, continuemos.
T1(LA RELACIÓN ESPECIAL)
En 1945 el presidente Roosvelt y el rey Saudí
Ibn Saud sellaron el pacto petróleo por defensa,
un pacto por el que Estados Unidos logró
petróleo a precios razonables al tiempo que
como contraprestación garantizaba la seguridad
del reino saudí.
Fue el comienzo de una larga amistad que dejaría
una profunda huella en la historia mundial.
Aunque realmente ese no fue el primer gran
contacto entre los dos países, 12 años antes,
en 1933, el gobierno saudí se asoció con
la Standard Oil Company del mismísimo Rockefeller.
Y así poco a poco se fueron forjando estrechos
vínculos entre los dos países.
Por ejemplo, Estados Unidos estableció una
delelgación en Jeddah en 1942, elevándola
a embajada en 1949.
Por su parte, el rey Ibn Saud instó a los
Estados Unidos a abrir un consulado en Dhahran
en 1944 para servir a los ciudadanos estadounidenses
empleados por la Arabian American Oil Company,
ahora conocida como Aramco.
En 1943, invitó a los Estados Unidos a construir
un aeródromo en Dhahran, que la fuerza aérea
de los Estados Unidos mantuvo hasta 1962.
El entendimiento era tal que en 1944, Estados
Unidos extendió el programa de préstamo
y arriendo a Arabia Saudí, para que este
país pudiera comprar un montón de equipos
en el gigantesco supermercado de armas de
los Estados Unidos.
Y poco después en 1951 ambos estados firmaron
un Acuerdo de Asistencia de Defensa Mutua
que, por ejemplo, estableció la primera Misión
de Entrenamiento Militar de Estados Unidos
en el reino saudí.
Pero, un momento, porque pese a todo Riad
siempre mantuvo una política exterior independiente
y a diferencia de otros países del Consejo
de Cooperación del Golfo siempre ha tenido
muchas reservas a la presencia de tropas norteamericanas
en su territorio.
(Por ejemplo, al gobierno saudí le costó
mucho tomar la decisión de aceptar el despliegue
de medio millón de soldados norteamericanos
durante la primera Guerra del Golfo.
Y más recientemente, durante la invasión
de Afganistán tras el 11S los saudíes no
permitieron que los norteamericanos utilizaran
su territorio para llevar a cabo operaciones
militares al tiempo que posteriormente fueron
muy críticos con la invasión de Irak.
Y todo ello por no hablar de los dos embargos
petroleros liderados por Arabia Saudí en
1967 tras la guerra de los seis días y en
1973 tras la Guerra Árabe-israelí.
Sobre todo este segundo embargo petrolero
causó estragos en Estados Unidos.)
Así que tal y como podéis ver no hablamos
precisamente de una relación de amor incondicional.
Para nada.
La relación especial entre Riad y Washington
ha sido una parte clave de la política exterior
norteamericana durante las últimas décadas,
pero la relación siempre ha estado marcada
por los desencuentros, los recelos y la desconfianza.
Y de hecho otros países del Golfo Pérsico
tienen relaciones mucho más estrechas con
Estados Unidos:
Por ejemplo Bahréin es la sede de la quinta
flota de Estados Unidos, Kuwait acoge a miles
de soldados norteamericanos en ocho bases
y en Qatar Estados Unidos alberga desde 1996
la base de al-Udeid, una de las bases aéreas
más importantes de la potencia norteamericana
en todo el mundo.
Las cosas mejoraron, no obstante, con Trump
en La Casa Blanca.
El ex-presidente apostó por Arabia Saudí
en detrimento de Qatar a la hora de fijar
sus prioridades en Oriente Medio, incluso
aunque ello supuso la salida de su Secretario
de Estado Rex Tillerson y a pesar de que Qatar
es un estrechísimo aliado de Washington.
Pero si ahí pareció surgir un cierto romance,
la llegada al poder de Joe Biden ha significado
tooodo lo contrario.
(Los saudíes consideran a la actual administración
como la heredera de la Administración Obama
que respaldó las primaveras árabes, quiso
reducir la presencia norteamericana en Oriente
Medio y selló el acuerdo nuclear con Irán.
Todo lo cual enfureció al gobierno saudí
liderado por aquel entonces por el fallecido
rey Abdallah.
Para colmo, Biden, a diferencia de Trump,
ha sido tremendamente crítico con el régimen
saudí tras el macabro, atroz y vil asesinato
del periodista Jamal Khashoggi.
El actual presidente de Estados Unidos llegó
a calificar a Arabia Saudí de ser un país
paria.)
Pero, ojo, queridos amigos, amigas, que todos
estos recelos y desencuentros no son solo
cosa del gobierno saudí.
Mohamed Bin Salmón está impulsando una gran
transformación en el país, os hemos hablado
de ello en un montón de vídeos, sin embargo
no es visto particularmente con buenos ojos
por los norteamericanos.
Digamos que en Washington consideran que el
nuevo líder saudí es una persona demasiado
impulsiva y en la que difícilmente se puede
confiar.
Fijaos.
(En Washington ntienden que este personaje
ha destruido casi por completo el equilibrio
de poderes de la realeza saudí; que está
reformando el sistema político saudí para
que todo gire en torno a su persona; que decidió
involucrase de forma temeraria en la guerra
de Yemen pese a las advertencias de que sería
un enorme error; que ordeno el vil asesinato
de Khashoggi y que, para colmo, ha intentado
chantajear a Estados Unidos con su política
petrolero a en diferentes ocasiones.)
Y todo ello por no hablar del golpe silencioso
que perpetró en 2017 cuándo derrocó y encarceló
al Príncipe Heredero Mohammad bin Nayef,
quien, precisamente, tenía unas relaciones
muy buenas con Estados Unidos gracias a su
lucha contra la presencia de Al Qaeda en el
país.
Demasiado para Washington.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué explica tantos desencuentros?
¿No se suponía que ambos países tenían
una relación especial e incluso una dependencia
mutua en campos tan importantes como la energía,
la seguridad o la defensa?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, lo cierto es
que durante las últimas dos décadas se ha
producido un giro coperniquiano:
Estados Unidos ha dejado de necesitar el petróleo
saudí.
Y eso ha supuesto todo un punto de inflexión.
Hoy las exportaciones a Estados Unidos representan
menos del 5% de las exportaciones de crudo
saudíes, un petróleo que hoy se dirige fundamentalmente
al lejano oriente, sobre todo a países como
China, Japón, Corea del Sur o Taiwán.
Tan solo las exportaciones a China representan
más del doble que las exportaciones a Estados
Unidos.
Y podéis creerme cuándo os digo que esto,
esto lo ha cambiado todo.
La revolución del shale oil en Estados Unidos
hizo que Washington dejara de darle tanta
importancia a Oriente Medio.
Y así estábamos cuándo para colmo llegó
la Invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Atentos.
T2(UNA CUESTIÓN DE BOLSILLO)
Puede terminar siendo un enorme punto de inflexión.
Riad se ha negado una y otra vez a condenar
a Moscú por la cruel invasión de Ucrania
e incluso le ha manifestado su apoyo como
socios del grupo conocido como OPEP+.
Mientras La Casa Blanca lideraba una campaña
para aislar a Rusia, los líderes de Arabia
Saudita seguiían manifestando cosas como
esta:
(Arabia Saudí señala su apoyo al papel de
Rusia en Opec+ a medida que aumenta la presión
sobre las sanciones.
FT)
Y lo que resulta aún mucho peor para los
intereses norteamericanos:
Arabia Saudí se ha negado tajantemente a
bombear mucho más petróleo para intentar
mitigar el efecto de las sanciones contra
Rusia.
Unas sanciones que han llevado los precios
del petróleo y del gas a sus máximos en
más de una década.
Claro que todo tiene una explicación.
Amigos, amigas, Arabia sigue siendo el mayor
exportador mundial de crudo y con el barril
de Brent a más de 100 dólares, el dinero
está entrando de nuevo en las arcas saudíes
a raudales.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os hemos contado
cómo este país se enfrenta a un futuro complicado:
por un lado su población es muy joven y está
acostumbrada a un estilo de vida relativamente
alto.
Por otro sus ingresos petroleros ya no dan
para mantener a una población cada vez más
grande en una economía que fundamentalmente
sigue dependendiendo del oro negro.
En Arabia básicamente o trabajas para el
gobierno o para la industria petrolera.
El
gobierno de Mohamed Bin Salman quiere cambiar
esta situación y lo está haciendo con planes
como Visión 2030.
El problema es que para llevar a cabo estos
planes el país necesita dinero, mucho dinero.
Y financieramente los últimos años fueron
muy pero que muy malos para el reino.
Entre los años 2015 y 2020, la caída de
los precios del petróleo hizo que el país
consumiera una parte sustancial de sus reservas
de dinero.
Hablamos de cientos de miles de millones,
un agujero que parecía conducirlos directamente
al abismo financiero.
Pero ahora eso ha cambiado.
Los nuevos precios del petroleo implican que
ahora Arabia Saudí tiene margen para recomponer
sus reservas y volver a financiar inversiones
en empresas extranjeras y en grandes proyectos
que reduzcan la dependencia del crudo.
C1(“Las ganancias inesperadas de los ingresos
adicionales que obtendremos de los altos precios
del petróleo se invertirán esencialmente
en resiliencia.
Ya sea reponiendo reservas, pagando la deuda
o invirtiendo en proyectos de transformación
únicos a través de nuestro fondo de riqueza,
eso realmente nos ayuda a acelerar los planes
de diversificación".
Faisal Alibrahim, ministro de economía y
planificación de Arabia Saudí)
Incluso el gobierno saudí está pensando
en vender más acciones de ARAMCO ahora que
esta empresa se ha disparado en bolsa y ha
vuelto a convertirse en la empresa más valiosa
del mundo tras superar a Apple.
Pero para lograr todos estos planes el país
necesita que los precios del petróleo sigan
al alza durante una buena temporada.
Tan solo durante el 2022 se espera que el
país ingrese por sus ventas de petróleo
más de 280 mil millones de dólares, unos
180 mil millones más que en los años anteriores.
Y eso, eso amigos, es mucho, mucísimo dinero.
El apoyo a Rusia puede tensar lo suficiente
como para garantizar que esos ingresos sigan
llegando, y además puede que en Riad estén
pensando que cuándo la producción rusa comience
a reducirse por las sanciones ellos puedan
colocar mucho más petróleo sin que esto
haga caer sustancialmente los precios.
Esto le podría dar al reino un margen de
3 o 4 años de ingresos extraordinarios: Y
ojo que podemos estar hablando de más de
500 o 600 mil millones de dólares.
Una fortuna con la que poder acelerar sus
planes de diversificación económica.
Claro que mucho cuidado con los planes milagrosos,
lo que en España conocemos como los cuentos
de la lechera.
Atentos.
T3(NO VENDAS LA PIEL ANTES DE CAZAR AL OSO)
Puede que Estados Unidos ya no sea un cliente
tan importante y puede que ahora Riad tenga
otras prioridades, pero su relación con el
gigante norteamericano sigue siendo indispensable
para la Casa Saud.
Por mucho que le pese a Mohamed Bin Salman,
Estados Unidos sigue siendo terriblemente
importante para Arabia.
Estados Unidos es la sede de las grandes finanzas,
el comercio y las grandes multinacionales
de todo el mundo.
Tan sólo Arabia Saudí, un país que busca
desesperadamente diversificar su economía
del petróleo, tiene invertidos más de 800
mil millones de dólares en Estados Unidos
frente a menos de 100 mil en China.
Y sí, aquí alguno podría pensar que esto
en todo caso es una debilidad para Estados
Unidos, que Arabia podría coger su dinero
e irse con él a otra parte.
Sin embargo, eso no resulta tan fácil: Arabia
quiere diversificar su economía del petróleo
y para ello necesita a las grandes multinacionales
norteamericanos.
La petromonarquía tampoco tiene fácil encontrar
otro destino dónde depositar semejantes cantidades
de dinero con total seguridad y liquidez.
(Y no solo se trata de una cuestión económica.
Desde el punto de vista militar la dependencia
es incluso mayor.
Las Fuerzas Armadas saudíes dependen casi
completamente de la industria militar norteamericana.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre 2015 y
2019 el 73% de las compras militares saudíes
se hicieron a empresas norteamericanas.
Tan solo entre los años 2008 y 2020 los saudíes
se gastaron en armas de Estados Unidos más
de 145 mil millones de dólares.)
Por otra parte, la invasión rusa de Ucrania
le ha dado a Riad una nueva oportunidad de
ganar influencia y recomponer su relación.
Estados Unidos ahora necesita otra vez petróleo…
Y lo necesita esta vez no tanto para sí mismo,
como para calmar un mercado terriblemente
estresado antes de que los precios del petróleo
empiezan a fracturar sus alianzas internacionales
contra Rusia.
Para eso…
Y para las elecciones de 2024.
Porque veréis, la evidencia dice que cada
cambio de 10 dólares por dólar en el precio
del petróleo crudo resulta en un cambio de
25-30 centavos en el precio de un galón de
gasolina, y por cada centavo que aumenta el
precio promedio de la gasolina de los Estados
Unidos, se pierden más de mil millones de
dólares al año en gasto adicional discrecional
de los consumidores.
Es decir, hablamos de decenas y decenas de
miles de millones que las empresas pueden
perder por el camino.
Y llegar a unas elecciones con el precio de
la gasolina disparado, las empresas perdiendo
negocios por valor de decenas de miles de
milllones y la economía tambaleándose, en
Estados Unidos es casi una sentencia: la derrota
electoral es un hecho.
Y tampoco podemos olvidar, aunque su peso
sea cada vez menos relevante, el importante
papel que puede jugar Arabia Saudí en materia
de seguridad y estabilidad regional.
Qué es justo lo que Estados Unidos necesita
para salir corriendo de Oriente Medio y poder
centrarse en su gran objetivo política, militar
y económico: Asia-Pacífico.
C2(Arabia Saudita es un socio crítico para
nosotros en el tratamiento del extremismo
en la región, en el tratamiento de los desafíos
planteados por Irán, y también espero continuar
el proceso de construcción de relaciones
entre Israel y sus vecinosAntony J. Blinken,
Secretario de Estado de Estados Unidos)
Sea como sea, un próximo viaje de Biden a
la región nos dejará claro si la relación
puede recomponerse o por contra está herida
de muerte.
De momento Riad ha trasladado las primeras
señales de que podría estar dispuesta a
dar su brazo a torcer:
N2(Arabia Saudí está lista para bombear
más petróleo si la producción rusa se hunde
bajo prohibición.
FT)
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que la relación entre Arabia Saudi
y Estados Unidos puede recomponerse?
¿Debe Estados Unidos buscar reforzar su vieja
alianza o por contra debería empezar a considerar
a Riad como un país no amistoso?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvideis darle a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.